[Musique]
très heureux de retrouver pour ce nouvel
épisode d'encore vous avec aujourd'hui
un invité que vous avez forcément déjà
vu au cinéma ou à la télé il a de
l'expérience il en a vu passer et c'est
normal car il a l'oeil aujourd'hui je
reçois l'éducateur en fin de carrière
qui a repéré le potentiel de ce jeune
défavorisé
indicateur en fin de carrière qui a
repéré le potentiel de ce jeune
pas de ça avec voir avec du chlore
souvent quand on retrouve au début de
vos films ça va pas vous êtes perdu la
foi en votre métier votre femme vous
quittez vos enfants vous dénigrent je
rencontre ce jeune et là je me dis waouh
ce gamin il a quelque chose mais il est
où là derrière je pense que tu sais où
il est
en toi où l'attendait une chronique en
non moi j'ai pas besoin de mentor à la
mvila aux têtes brûlées à tige ou le
malin tu fais le comique tu bafouille
débâcle était question pour des missions
les bactéries bon et moi je vais te
sortir de ce merdier d'amendé déjà vous
parler mieux et puis moi je vous
absolument rien demandé sur 38 demande
jamais rien toi mais je vais t'expliquer
un truc au début tu vas me détester
classique mais je veux juste dire que
l'homme que tu cherchais ce n'est pas
celui que tu es ou qui étaient puisque
tu les
villes avant tu sait à peine lire
scolarité chaotique mais tient bon
rachid hoguette warda moi je m'appelle
alex et là je pense que vous dépassez
les bornes de sieste je t'ai dit tu
m'appelles pas comme ça c'est clair je
sais pas comment ça se passait chez toi
ici il ya des règles la première ça
s'appelle le respect entre ça d'accord
d'accord
alors justement au niveau de ces
rencontres que vous faites comment ça se
passe vous traîner près des cours de
lycée a pas marre de bousiller ta vie
bordel moi la mienne elle est faite je
m'en fous je suis pas ta mère mais pense
à elle justement tu veux pas juste une
fois qu'elle soit fière de toi oui si
j'aime juste une fois
dans sa pauvre existence elle enchaîne
les ménages
calculée qui joue sa paye au pmu 1 au
lieu de payer des soins dentaires [ __ ]
pauvre gosse que tu aimais fois
problèmes de dents ça va aller mais
balance mal à s'en sortent à coller à
l'aréna sortir ces sortes harawa voilà
allez non oui écoute je vais précaire
avec toi quoi on va réaliser ton rêve
donne moins six mois on n'a qu'une
minute ça m'a aussi
voilà ça y est ça y était prêt et gamin
voilà j'aime la présenter cette émission
là c'est vraiment ce que je faisais déjà
adresse ne me remercie pas acheté en
supplie engage pas tous hincapie je veux
juste que tu voles de mes propres ailes
eh ben voilà maintenant on sait pourquoi
personne ne l'aiment
pas moi qui décide
c'est toi qui m'a sauvé tu vas aller
voir ma famille dire que je même qu'on
ait vu le divorce à bas des pêcheurs ou
parce que j'adore ça tout à l'heure mais
c'est la femme d'âge mûr qui a décidé de
refaire sa vie avec un jeune prof de
zumba
[Musique]
mais ici je demande au moins la garde
alternée
ouais tu as raison
tu sais que tu prends un grand avocat